even today is big as Nike is with over
60,000 employees the key key thing is
people I think in many ways the success
that Nike has today really came out of
the soul-searching that was done in the
mid 1980s when Reebok went past us I
know they asked me and one of the rare
TV interviews from 25 years ago if I
wanted to meet the president of Reebok
and I said no I said I don't know him I
don't like him and I don't want to like
him it's more than just a business it's
more than just sports it is a mission
he's an American business magnate and
philanthropist he's the co-founder and
chairman emeritus of Nike he has an
estimated net worth of twenty five point
five billion dollars he's still night
and here's my take on his top ten rules
for success rule number eight is my
personal favorite and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end for some
special bonus clips also as Phil is
talking if he says something that is
meaningful to you that you want to
remember make sure to write it down in
the comments below and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired as
well you're a runner with a track coach
now you're very fond of an accountant
and a Stanford Business School grad
produced a crazy idea how did it go to
you well it was a combination of two
things it came off the running track at
Oregon and out of the classroom at the
Stanford Business School and that barman
was always tinkering with shoes and he
began to have some of his good runners
not just his hacks like me you know
where were the shoes and they were
wearing him quite successfully and he
was very sincere and believing the
weight of the shoe was very important to
a runner and so that registered then all
the best shoes were being made in
Germany and it made no sense that he
would make shoes at Letus and Puma make
no sense that they'd be made in Germany
so I wrote the paper about they should
make them in Japan and the idea built
and built and built and it became a
crazy idea to everybody
me and my college professor when I'm in
my old track coat if you were talking to
a young entrepreneur today what would
you say about how a great team gets put
together about the role of a CEO in
supporting shaping interacting with that
team yeah a man's life and death I think
even today is big as Nike is with over
60,000 employees the key key thing is
people so when you're starting out
obviously you're getting the right
people is that's life and death and and
then not only the right people by
getting them work together and work for
a common purpose I've always said to 9s
working together will be to tens working
apart any day how do you do that well
the right people's number one and then
giving the environment and maybe a
little bit of leadership that allows
them to keep doing that and the
environment for good for the ability to
get different people to work together
I'm looking for sort of how you would
articulate what is that what is that
thing you put in the environment well
now you're getting into into management
and there's all kinds of different
management styles that but and and you
have to kind of recognize that each
person is an individual so there's but I
always liked Sparky Anderson the manager
of the Cincinnati Reds he says do you
treat all players the same hell no he
says Johnny Bench wants a day off he
gets it off a rookie wants a day off I
said get your ass out on the field and I
think that's a good management principle
by itself
the key thing for us was the product and
our whole focus for the first ten years
of the company was building a better
mousetrap having a better running shoe
having a better basketball shoe having
more cushioning in different shoes and
innovating like every six months and
spending a lot of money and research and
development spending a lot of money in a
lab and the product process really was
developed for in advance of anything
else that we did most important thing is
you have to there's two sides is really
sort of the intellectual or mental side
you have to pick a business that has a
niche you have to have a reason to
succeed you have to be something like we
were doing say Japan can be Germany and
manufacturing of this type of a product
that was the niche really and
and on that you just have to have a
total and complete passion because
there's going to be so many dark moments
you know I think the dark moments are
true for any entrepreneur or any startup
company I'm sure that you talk to Steve
Jobs and Apple you can see many many
dark dark moments ours happened to last
a little longer than most of them but
you really emotionally have to be
prepared for those dark moments hmm I
think every entrepreneur I've ever
spoken to which would echo that yeah
there are dark moments everything's on
the line that's the life of an
entrepreneur and she's gonna be into it
you better be prepared for that before
there was success there was defeat we
were kicked out of two banks we borrowed
money once from a shoe box manufacturer
to meet the payroll on another time we
had to sell $2,500 at a national PE
convention in Seattle Washington on a
Friday so we could meet payroll on
Monday and all those cases the lesson
from the fields and the courts the
lessons of competitive response were the
most valuable of all I think yeah in
many ways the success that Nike has
today really came out of the
soul-searching that was done in the mid
1980s when Reebok went past us that
essentially we had to cite who we were
and what we were and try and build off
of that and and really defend those
values that really determined it
dictated what our persona was as a
company
night refocus the brand on pure sport
and reorganize the company ten
commandments emerged break the rules
fight the law
this isn't much about battles about
business it's worth you're pretty and
lastly if we do the right things we'll
make money damn near automatic I have in
my travels occasionally met promising
young people insist they are not going
to ask for help along the way they want
to figure it out themselves mine was the
opposite approach it is hard enough out
there get all the help you can getting
help really just a part of a lifelong
search for wisdom brands or you know one
of the most interesting parts of
business but I mean basically a brand
stands for something
it creates an emotion in a person's mind
either positive or negative that brings
out all kinds of reactions to that brand
and when we got to start our own brand
and have our own name we were very
ambitious and some of the things that we
wanted it to stand for but I mean I see
stop and think about brands around the
world Sony and coca-cola and rolls-royce
why they all stand for very different
things but they all create an emotional
response and something that's really
strong and powerful I was developing an
unhealthy contempt for adidas you say or
maybe it was healthy I despised them
yeah I'm curious what you make of the
competition right now adidas is coming
back from a soft patch and they're
upstarts like Under Armour that are
making a headway on athletes and on
sales mmm-hmm
well I think I'm sort of a warrior by
nature and so everybody is a concern and
but I'm still the same as I was before I
know they asked me and one of the rare
TV interviews from 25 years ago if I
wanted to meet the president of Reebok
and I said no I said I don't know him I
don't like him and I don't want to like
him and I still feel that way about the
competition
what about Under Armour in the US market
is there one agree they're one of them
there lots of them that we compete with
then but believe me we will compete Phil
Knight built Nikes corporate
headquarters in Portland Oregon as a
shrine to sporting excellence it's part
Cathedral part University campus each
building has its own patron saint icons
adorn every wall
as they walk down the cloisters
disciples are encouraged to contemplate
the deeds of Nike heroes past and
present Heritage's is is the glue that
holds great companies together because
you have to love what you're doing
because this is the way people have
chosen to work in the world and if
you're going to work for a company you
might as well love what you do and for
us it's understanding the roots and that
gives people the energy and the fire and
the appreciation for competition in
sport and that passion you can only get
it if you're if you're hooked into why
you exist to me our employees understand
what are we doing here where why do we
exist that they understand that
everybody excels to approach the main
door workers walk along the rocky road
which symbolizes man's journey from an
uncertain past to a more promising Nike
future it's more than just a business
it's more than just sports it is a
mission I mean this is what we've
committed our lives to doing so let's
make it something worthwhile
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because mr.
old-fashioned lover asked me to so
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it down
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do
I'd love to know which it feels top-10
rules have the biggest impact on you and
why what change you're going to make in
your life for business as we all have
watching this video leave in the
comments I will join in the discussion
finally what do you have a quick shout
out to or kita Guterres up a pronounce
that okay thank you so much for buying
my book it really means a lot to me
those are you watching you want a chance
at a shout out in the future video make
sure to pick up a copy of the book and
email in your receipt so you can keep
track thank you guys so much for
watching
continue to believe or whatever you're
one where it is and I'll see you soon
the swoosh the very famous Nike swoosh
how much you pay for that design there
was a graphic art student at Portland
State that had done some work for us and
she charged two dollars an hour and we
said how about coming up with a with the
logo for the shoe and she spent
seventeen and a half hours on it so it
cost us thirty five dollars but and as I
said it's easily worth it it's turned
out to be a fairly iconic but when we
went public in 1980 we gave her five
hundred shares of stock but she still
owns she's never sold a share and that's
worth a million dollars now too good for
her yes a good book came out it story
had a happy ending